please welcome my heart tamara maury
housley
[Music]
oh my goodness
i promise myself i'm not gonna cry it's
so
good to see you ladies you you you
always look so beautiful
and i'm so proud of you tamara mowry
housley makes a tear-filled return to
the reel
i miss that and you know i love you girl
i'm not gonna cry
on tuesday the former the real co-host
returned to her old daytime tv home for
the first time since her departure in
july
and the whole crew lonnie adrian genie
and garcelle bouvet who replaced her
were all over the top excited to have
her back
behind the scenes i've been trying to to
get this
together so i'm i'm i'm really happy
that i'm here today
tamara announced in july her plans to
leave the reel after
seven years as a co-host but still it's
nothing but love
i support them i i also you know
and they support me that's what's
awesome they support me
tam even listed off all the things she
misses about her girls
i'll start with you a ah i
miss just our hugs i i miss looking into
your eyes
and kind of like just connecting adrien
and i have a way of speaking
with each other without words i i
i i miss that and you know i love you
girl i'm not gonna cry
that's when the actress got a little
choked up
lonnie oh i missed hugging her even
though she doesn't like hugging me
genie i miss in briefing her just kind
of like snuggling up
next to me and uh being mischievous
while we were doing briefing we would
always share like little fun
secrets and uh talk very sexual
i think a lot of people don't know that
we would really
say some interesting
funny dirty things back in october et
caught up with tamara
and she opened up about her close bond
with the ladies
which she says will never change the
girls will always be a part of my family
so in a way i feel like i haven't yeah
may not be physically in front of the
camera
i mean i had i would just talk to
you know most of the girls just just
recently so we will be a family
for forever it's weird to say but i feel
like they're
we're still i'm still there i still talk
to the girls
i support the girls still individually
i do it individually because they're all
they're all doing their own thing
and the sister sister star said she was
looking forward to a new chapter in life
living in napa with her husband adam
housley and their two kids
seven-year-old aiden and five-year-old
aria
there's one word i can think of and it's
peace
i have peace i have peace because i'm
with my family
and my family rejuvenates me so being
around my family being there for my
children they're at an age right now
where they want mommy
around um you know i like i'm a hands-on
parent i like you know to to
help them whether it's in you know
soccer dance
obviously it's pretty coveted um but we
still do those things
at home with school with with homework
flash forward to tuesday tamara echoed
exactly that
oh my goodness you guys they love
mommy home that's one of the main
reasons why you know i just kind of
wanted to
create some type of balance i thought
because i'm spending so much more time
with them they would get sick of me it's
the
absolute opposite aria is like on my hip
aiden is is on my leg and
and literally i'm just trying to to
navigate
you know throughout throughout the house
but they're thriving
and yes they've seen her hit sitcom
sister sister
mom that girl has my face
and they love it oh yes absolutely
aria just recently she was carrying her
little ipad
and i was like i hear my voice she knows
how to find the show
on netflix she watches it on her own
and aiden loves it it's kind of surreal
to see them
watch you and then laugh at the jokes
i'm like oh my gosh i made my kids laugh
you were loving
on that show and to be introduced to
your daughter how does that feel
i want to know how i feel i feel old
that's how i feel i'm like whoa it's
like it's it's surreal because in my
mind i still feel like i'm
at that little you know that little girl
i was uh 15 16 when we first started
and i'm like i can't believe i'm sitting
here you know
talking to my daughter about this show
and i swear she knows how to find it on
her computer
she has her little little little ipad
and again you will hear
sister sister never knew how
i'm like are you watching sister sister
she's like uh-huh
i like that [ __ ] not only are her kids
fans she says they also want to follow
in her showbiz footsteps
they want to be in mommy's movies that's
what they say she wants to be on tv
she kind of hinted to me she's five
um i'm exploring a little bit of it you
know just to make sure
that this is something that she really
you know she really wants to do
um and i'm gonna i obviously i have to
support her
you know 100 100 percent so who knows we
shall see
she said she wants to be in one of
mommy's movies as for tamara
she and her husband own and operate a
napa vineyard
and tasting room and while she loves it
she told et
she has no plans to quit acting i
haven't given up hollywood
i feel like i am going to i will be in
hollywood as long as i'm having fun
i've been so grateful to have worked for
so long in hollywood
i'm now at an age right now where i can
say
wait i want to spend this much time
doing this
and this much time doing that
so the choices that i'm making
right now the number one question i say
is
well am i gonna have enough time with my
family so what's next for tamara
well let's just call her a triple threat
actress host
and full-time mom i love acting
acting is like oh gosh it's like my
my my number one like love i
loved doing my talk show i i you know it
was great it was
it i did it for seven years i built an
amazing um
family i learned a lot about myself
about
people the importance of of your voice
and not being afraid to
you know vocalize your opinion because
you never know who is out there that
truly needs to hear your words